[Music]
hey guys happy Tuesday normally I would
just be like yeah every Tuesday it's you
know it's destiny time there's red theme
so you know crimson days is an event
running now in destiny - it's basically
their Valentine's Day
oops there you go Valentine's Day event
figured it'd be a there's an actual
reason to hop back in I guess if you
want to collect certain things if you go
to tests I believe if you on any of your
characters if you log in I heard this
works on multiple characters you're
gonna get a crimson day's Ingram crap
yeah hold on this is what happens when
you haven't played in a while and you
just got a shitload of engrams hold on
should have thought about that before
the stream it's actually been a while
since I played destiny I just haven't
had a reason to go back to it as most of
you probably don't have a reason to go
back to it I've actually been playing
more Monster Hunter than anything else
but there are a couple things at least
this time around with this event that
you can actually earn from doing stuff
so like one of the dances you get is the
flaunting dance and you can't get that
from this Engram this comes from Engram
but if you finish the nightfall which
I'm gonna do here with some of my clan
mates
you'll get that emote so finishing the
nightfall you're going to get the
flaunting dancing mode if you finish the
raid you're gonna get that steampunk ish
ward cliff coil skin and then if you do
five crimson pbt pvp type matches where
it's the 2v2 mode you're gonna get a
ghost shell and an emblem I believe from
shacks and then every time you level
you're getting a crimson Engram and
there's some other stuff let me see
there's some other stuff you can earn Oh
potentially this exotic Sparrow I think
you can earn also by doing crimson PvP
so at least if you do the raid nightfall
or raid layer you're gonna get something
some benefit out of it I'm just gonna
open this sick got up got a heartbreaker
did it gets speed oh it does have less
time to summon except it's slower but
because it's crimson Orient themed we
will use this heartbreaker also happy
pre Valentine's Day to everybody don't
forget it's tomorrow if you have you
know a loved one you care about maybe
your mom maybe a significant other I
would say probably don't go and buy
roses because that's kind of expensive
but you know cards always morrow okay
hopefully there's matchmaking up there's
the crap that went to the post
[Music]
we gotta go get our crimson emblem and
then we'll start also I'll be monitoring
chat so hi to everyone in chat and send
me your questions your comments your
concerns tell me if you've fallen off
destiny destiny kind of like I have or
if you know you still been on the train
still holding out hope and or if you
were on the Destiny train what games
have you kind of uh or fell off the
train rather which games are you guys
playing like I said I was playing I've
been playing Monster Hunter which has
really filled a niche for me that
destiny
used to fill but not any longer I've
fallen off destiny hard yeah I know
Calvin I know all right we're gonna do
the nightfall so we can get that
flaunting dance should be easy this week
it's torrent with on pyramidion which is
like basically a joke one I'm gonna head
on over and do that sorry arctos I hope
you're ready you fallen off so hard
sighs James yeah that's true what's up
lunatic how you doing does that mean - a
little gamer there's probably a lot of
dislikes because a lot of people don't
like destiny - anymore and I can
understand that I'm waiting for Kingdom
Come deliverance to download says
lunatic 19 I heard that game's kind of
jank right now but we've started to kind
of play - in the in the office at least
so I'm sure we'll have some some footage
and whatnot of that soon enough
apparently JM 76 who is one of the guys
here in this group says to follow his
rose petals we're only gonna be able to
like really Ryder Sparrow for like a
limited amount of time considering its
like which one called pyramidion what's
up Dustin dang I bought the division
recently because I fell off destiny -
says Keith Richards liver 420 yeah
division has had a lot of good solid
updates as of late
adding some good like new kind of like
that horde mode which is a good thing to
farm I like that that game has more
reasons to continue playing I guess
because you you can min/max your sets
and stuff like that destiny you used to
have something similar because of like
gun perks and things like that but they
don't have that anymore so it's kind of
like once you get your like better
Devils or you know kind of when you
master cored some of your the weapons
you actually want there's kind of no
reason oh you know what I'm not solar
alright you definitely if you're a Titan
I would suggest at least for this week's
nightfall that you go solar and you go
with that one chest I'll show you here
in a second because you will be once you
get super you're gonna be able to spam
your ability your grenade like pretty
pretty quickly so we'll call it what is
this thing called again Hollow fire or
something
yeah hollow fire heart pretty good for
solar Titan
destiny is dead a lot of people saying
it's dead yeah it it's it was definitely
dead before this update I think some
people are gonna come back at least do
the raid
you know once this week and probably
also do the nightfall get that free
emote and then probably stop that's what
I'm gonna do at least probably do the
the raid with my group maybe once this
week doing this knife all right now to
get the flaunting emotes and probably go
back to Monster Hunter personally but I
will still say that uh destiny still
feels destiny and desing to still feel
like some of the best shooting mechanics
that I've experienced in a FPS where's
his uh where's his spare oh all right
he's got rose petals cuz he's got the
undefeated that is one of the sparrows
you can earn oh I could just inspect him
for that thing our weight every
hopefully crimson doubles match makes
and you don't have to have an actual
person if not I might actually have to
ask somebody in the stream to
potentially share that crimson bond with
me so we can try to get through like
five or so matches the 2v2 is a little
different than your traditional PvP you
know if one of you dies the other does
more damage and I think like if you're
closer together like you regenerate
abilities faster so there's that to it
match makes sweet thanks Jim I mean I
personally how you're a good guy but
this isn't a good game that's oh crap
that's fair I don't know I still
personally enjoyed it for a while longer
than most
I should just be running by this stuff
like Arcos but I can understand why some
people are not a fan which is fair there
are still I'm sure there's still quite a
bit of people that still play this game
right not as much more recently but I'm
sure this this event will be a good
reason to for some people to get come
back hop in for you know as mentioned at
least to do you know nightfall do a raid
if you if you can get some of the the
stuff you can actually earn also they
did a thing where I think you won't get
as many duplicate or you won't get
duplicates anymore in the crimson
engrams which is good I'll crap which is
a step in the right direction obviously
but yeah bungees got some ground to make
up
and I don't know even for me it's like
the hope is that the next expansion it's
like good I guess otherwise you're
pretty much just at that point hoping
for like something as good as like
taking King was previously which is like
they're kind of big September update
that they do yearly update or yearly
anniversary rather so I'll get into some
PvP after this after we hopefully get
this flaunting emote
which is one of the reasons why I dam is
kind of going through this this time
around cousin wants that emote and as
mentioned I always like having something
where you know you can tangibly earn
something by doing it and not just
straight from the engrams so it's nice
to see that there's some of that I have
no void oh wait I lied my current gun is
void still still ready for the raid I
guess cuz rate layer rather because the
minotaurs and one otter are void so you
can see with hollow fire heart you can
kind of spam the grenades because if you
have super it basically lowers cooldown
and because it's torrent you're pretty
much your cooldowns are even lower so
we're just famine grenades
I mean strike your Titans still probably
fine because if you use a insurmountable
skull fort or whatever you're gonna get
your grenades back from mailing or
shoulder charging why are you watching
if it's a yeah I mean like if you guys
don't enjoy it I understand but you know
it is also the internet and people just
like to come in to talk trash about a
game it's almost like that Ralph Wiggum
like a meme you know it's already dead
like stop it
although I don't think this game is
actually like dead dead I just think
it's not in as good of a place as it
used to be but it's like it's kind of
become the new game that people just
like to talk crap about or whatever
downvote just why everyone is entitled
to their opinions
grenade spam city
Destinee three we got it right edition
maybe the funny thing is I feel like
okay so everyone was not so happy about
destiny or proper right original and
then I feel like they really you know
started to figure things out they
revamped things and taken King and the
game actually by the end of destiny was
a very solid game but for whatever
reason a lot of the stuff that they
learned through those years didn't
always didn't all transfer over to
testing two which was mind-boggling like
a lot of the good that they eventually
figured out that should have just been
in this game are like you know they're
coming in updates so like heroic strike
those are coming back like in May or
something like that they're gonna have
nightfall point stuff which was kind of
in the last game too so like a lot of
the Destiny one stuff is just not in
destiny two and it was like a lot of the
good stuff that they learned towards the
end of the cycle and I don't blame
Bungie necessarily as Dustin dang has
mentioned it's Activision's fault it is
in terms of like all that like monetary
stuff that people are talking about
right now a lot of that comes from you
know what I'm sure activision expects
out of them because you know they made
an investment so they need to find they
basically probably have some you know
some pressures to like or Bungie has
pressures to then have to do things to
you know try to recuperate some of that
expenditure from you know Activision et
cetera but I don't know that as a fact
it's just like logically that's probably
what it is you know I am just out of
primary Oh chill for a second as to not
die
can you get it if your level 10 no I
think you have to be at least the
minimum is at least level 25 stop
distance tree monster hunter I mean we
we street monster hunter once a week
monster idiotic so if you want to tune
into that Ben Janka and John Luke they
do their weekly live streams we've been
doing them on Friday because that's when
the the events start to update the
weekly kind of events that they have
going on in their game oh yeah
I I am enjoying Monster Hunter I have
gotten to the point though where like
I'm at like pretty much end game we're
like right about to get to the end end
game which is you know farming tempered
Elder Dragons and I don't know if it's
just because I've been using the same
weapon and I haven't really branched off
but I'm starting to get a little bit
bored but I think swapping weapons will
probably be the thing to help me kind of
get out of that lul ace McClain saying
play the division yeah I'm I've been
kind of wanting to do that the the thing
is my first character that I ever made
in the division when it came out oh gee
vanilla back in the day what's on an
Xbox because I don't know that's just
like the copy your version I got early
and I don't really want to play on xbox
but then at the same time I don't really
want to start all over but I heard that
it's not as hard to get back into it
like starting like it's it's not that
bad to regrind so if that's the case
maybe but yeah I understand everyone
telling under it like their their pains
and went up but as randoms
ever has mentioned you know we're gonna
play what we want to play I mean like
it's still here to be discussed it's
still here to talk about like you know
are you gonna play because of this event
or not if not that's fine like I find
that at the very least I'm definitely
gonna you know do what I'm doing here
which is the nightfall I would've did it
regardless of work and then I'm gonna
see if my group wants to do the raid
layer cuz that's like a you know
experience or something like that or not
sorry like a one-and-a-half hour
experience or one hour experience
depending on if we struggle or not yeah
this knife fall is like super fast super
easy especially if you're just doing it
on normal so you know bigger let's just
get it done and you know should be good
to go
but I mean today each their own like you
know like the stuff that they're adding
now in in the game is stuff that I wish
that was already in the getting like I
wish each of the events prior had a
thing where like if you actually just
did something you got something like
adding back the ability to finally like
buy stuff with like shards and like
coins is like like finally I guess it's
kind of crazy that it was so bad with
RNG before was just packages cuz I
basically played I would be playing an
iron banner it took me the first time on
my Titan 49 packages to get the whole
set which is like pretty ridiculous but
I still did it
you see lost sectors fixed a I did not
splob what what did they change in that
regard grab what if she'd even a throw
pie hammers him in a second here once we
lay down the fire here yes should
teleport over here at some point okay
there you go
don't even really have to hammer him but
just oh I think Arthur's just got killed
can't engage this Genesis mind up close
you'll just punt you Oh No okay dad same
thing alright so there you go got the
flaunting dance emote that went to my
posts because of course I never have
space for anything and let's get rid of
this some of this stuff so we can go
grab that so yeah that was a nightfall
easy peasy you know get the flaunting
dance emote guaranteed
thanks to my my group here for helping
out I look like super shredder and now
we'll go check out the crimson event and
if for some reason as somebody else in
chat at some point needs the nightfall
or something we could potentially run
the nightfall again at the end but I
want Playstation just so you know it's
how a real quick flaunting dance
whoops remaster destiny one ello just
kidding I respect everyone's opinions
it's just sad to see that this game sort
of fell flat good stream anyways that's
true blood slips I feel you man I I feel
like as I mentioned earlier right
destiny one got it took a while and then
it got to a really good place and then
destiny 2 came out and everyone was like
super you know excited you know
especially the the d1 community myself
included because we're like cool we
learned all these lessons from destiny 1
and we're getting these like quality of
life changes in destiny - and there's
all these things and then it just didn't
end up being as big as I think people
thought or wanted it to be and I for
some reason in my craziest wildest of
dreams thought there'd be like a like a
fourth class or something I thought when
we saw a cold heart we'd have like some
type of new ice element and elemental
type class I was like dude what would we
all right so what would the warlock one
be and like well
what tighten be and what would hunter be
and we got like a revamped version of
certain subclasses and that's kind of
about it yeah Bob Jones 1980 saying I
like test me too and still play but I'm
always playing by myself now yeah pretty
much I mean a lot of people falling off
and the other part of destiny - that's
kind of pretty important is it's a
social game right like in a perfect
world you're hoping to log in find a
friend or two maybe more so that you can
play together but you know as as things
get you know as there's less and less to
do in the game there's less and less
motivation and hop back in the game then
you yourself becomes less motivated to
get back in the game are there changes
in every burst yet I mean the only
change I can tell god David t88 is that
at least with the Crimson engrams this
time around it sounds like when you open
them it's not going to necessarily give
you duplicate items anymore until you've
actually gotten everything which is good
like postmasters completely out of space
if I do not retrieve my items they'll be
lost forever great I really need to
clean out my post I just cleaned it like
two slots out though alright thank God I
got the dance
that's what matters that's that's really
what matters here is the flaunt dance
you guys haven't seen the flaunt dance
I'll equip it
it looks like this it's almost like I
put a ring on it you know oh oh it is
it's Beyonce the flaunt the the flaunt
dance is single ladies pretty much
that's what JM was trying to tell me
earlier I think I'm a single dad is I'm
a single lettuce all right all right
let's see what we can do about this this
crimson PvP my guess is all right we got
to do like five matches I think yeah
crimson days we got too many people Oh
potential reward the undeterred it
sounds like oh you can potentially get a
crimson Prince um Ingram to you also
every time you level up your getting a
crimson crimson crimson I can't say that
word to save my life Ingram so alright
thank you to my boys in the GameSpot
clan there for joining I appreciate it I
am going to try to do this thing so it
shouldn't match make you I can't kick
him from the group sorry
arctos I just booted you off at Tower I
guess I could have just left I could
have just left that was in that was an
overuse and abuse of power there but
whatever alright let's try this out
single ladies dance um thanks for the
info what about the exp bar is that
still broken if you're talking about
that like thing from a long time ago
where like they were like throttling you
I don't know if they've like actually
changed that but like for whatever
reason for me personally that never
bothered me like it bothered a lot of
other people but I think I was never
bothered by the whole exp bar thing
because of the fact that in the past in
destiny one when you fully level the
full bar whatever that number was all
you got was a motive light it's like
great moto like this time around at
least when you
love bringing an illuminated Engram and
in this event the crimson Days event
you're actually getting encouraged
today's you know so I always read it as
like cool now that if I level I'm
getting something tangible that like I
actually want now granted the Engram
could be orangey and it could be crappy
but it's something I earned regardless
of the fact just by playing the game
I never even stared at that exp bar like
who cares I don't know that's just me
XP is now set at 120 K per level and for
this event you get both illuminated
anchors a day so there's your answer for
that god
thanks Bob but yeah like I don't know I
think for me like now that I don't play
this game on the regular it's actually
nice now that I haven't played destiny
in a while which is like kind of weird
for me at least to come back and play it
now in like a small dose so for me I've
been looking I looked at their roadmap
right I looked to see oh this burnout
map is also new well sort of you it's
it's burning shrine but they've you know
changed it a bit but for me it's nice to
kind of maybe just play for the bigger
events so I'm sure the one I'm looking
forward to a lot but is way down the
road is having iron banner finally be
6v6 again so that me and my actual raid
group can actually play together and not
have to like split up wow this brings
back trials of trials of Osiris or I
mean yeah trials of Osiris because of
that PvP mode from back in the day wow
I'm terrible
got one he's now powered up though the
other guy all right I should switch to
colony so he's a lot harder to kill but
we did it
despite my poor name switching to the
colony oh it just keeps going
interesting I thought that uh it would
be like a one you like win one and then
like so he should be empowered now to do
like way more damage each on your
partner Falls a combat you'll gain
increased health and ability energy I
just totally ran into them whoops
okay oh it's tied feel like I should
just wait for him to respond but we're
warming up also I should not be solar I
should be striker which I will switch
here in a second Wow get your abilities
back real fast
I should be spamming is like having
torrent holy smokes what oh I did not
know there ahead alright whatever that's
fine it's fine
tis totally fine kinetic yeah that's
fine shut up Jax alright
that's crazy
all you're so lucky why was I even
blinded there for like the hottest of
seconds
I regret this one
I should run my de
seconds
oh this is bad
No kill them both get teamed up oh no oh
I would not
oh thank you guys thanks for walking
into that all right I got the two-piece
to win the round almost choked it how
long does this event run for uh that's a
good question Alfie when we double check
that for you probably more than a week I
would assume like ho well at least a
week at least a week
oh this is kind of new I don't remember
this library being in here all right
you gotta get that heavy
all right we traded just good do you
have discord I mean technically yes but
I mean we will be using it here
it's like a reskin of meat of an old map
I guess oh go baby go Oh Golden Gun no I
should have challenged why did I
challenge that's so dumb there's my
teammate cool
although hammers is probably a better
super than like oh he's one shot come on
I thought we were a team firing it's all
about team firing I got shut down trying
to slam them both and we lose because of
that rip oh we tied it
crap he's one shot he's getting the
heavy no how'd you have slammed though
Adam
what oh that's so stupid
so the point doesn't matter because it's
still based off of how many kills you
have so I should have just chased them
four kills which is good to know so
first at three two-minute rounds it's an
old map from d1 yes
walk into it yeah boy yes people still
play this game Rick see surprising
agree with Jamie this game still fun I'm
just not many people to play with
anymore dude
I just walked into the wall I thought I
got body bump my my teammate
we got a hurry or I can just feed I
agree with that
Erica to randomize the intrinsic perks
go storm call
oh my god
laughs whoa all right clearly me sucking
with the with the Devils so when you get
off what up we'll only tell you what up
how you doing I would definitely like to
like try to min max weapons again that
would be great actually
yeah I got one shader from finishing a
match didn't see if I got an Ingram
though I don't think I did
yeah well I also full-on engrams she
could no I can't discard right no that's
cool you get legendary shards alright we
made space alright try to win one here
feeling good I forget if I have dim on
here
I need we'll see if we get that that map
again
they also buffed Prometheus lens ik back
again like kind of but it didn't feel
that good when we used it in the right
layer
can you play this on Xbox yes you can't
take go get those Kate stashes nah man
one of these days when it when the new
expansion comes out it might be time to
just blow all those oh we're leading how
all right
join the game we're already ahead diggin
it I killed someone and then died it was
only 280 did you kill him heavy that's a
sneaky spot wonder if he meant to go
there
and colonies a fun gun if you don't have
one I would definitely recommend getting
one if you can they're sold it the other
week it's been a while though since
that's bad it's very bad spot to be in
double Golden Gun hope hope they trade
at the minimum someone just blew their
load
you gotta come after me if you want this
ketchup here
that's fine
pretty dry right now flop buzz so laters
again SWAT and chat have a good day see
you later Jamie
Salcedo thank you
hello run away Oh
go run to me run to me run to me always
grime a heavy
he's got the shotty oh man I've almost
hit me trying to set my snipe with the
ante Oh
all right I got smash which is good
you've got 30 seconds
had to try to stay away because he had a
shoddy try to be with my teammate right
no no he was one shot but not a fan of
lightning grenade I think it's good but
pulse grenades more broken or was more
broken before dang it
alright it's got trying to make a
comeback make sure to save smash for
last round used to snipe down this
street
nope right by him Oh
Wak
alright well your peers they're gonna
come back most likely oh that guy is
actually not level 25 didn't doing
crimson so that could be a faster
incorrect
we gotta find they're just gonna camp
right
oh I see why would you not shoot that
entire time all right
nice you got Golden Gun on one wow that
is so freaking dirty he's just gonna run
okay is that Uriel's gift no it's a
positive outlook those weapons are so
useless
[Music]
hello
you can do it I believe in you
oh I'm just dead dead I did not know
that okay learning again apparently when
you when you like lose or when you're in
overtime overtime you only have one
death that's kind of cool
I like that what's up Kane the one I'm
not matching I don't like it
although perks are better on this this
guy
I rocket going back to the the white and
gold here all except the helmet
chef McNasty says what keeps you guys so
consistent I want to love this game so
much but makes it just so hard yeah part
of what helps for me is that I'm just
lucky enough to have some you know
friends that still enjoy playing the
game that I can kind of like hop on and
play with them which obviously is is a
pretty big factor but I know masterworks
did help a little bit but you know Jake
clausal I just beat neck hmm it did say
sudden death on your spine yeah I took
that as like a you know it's sudden
death in in like in the sense that it
was like the last round I don't know
James disappointing yeah you know I'm
disappointed in myself too I could have
played better although I didn't look at
my my stats after the fact I'm gonna try
having a scout in a and upward not on
the new map now that's need to have
enough date for Valentine's Day yes mean
him no gaming crimson days is the
Valentine's Day I don't cherish my
brother
this map feels too big for TV too but
whatever
see where you spend so much time looking
for each other I guess at least there's
a point of interest as heavy standing on
grenade
stuck in animation oh I have the same
partner
or did the other guy come from getting
pinched
oh no wait how did he get all his life
back what okay
I don't understand was it because he was
near his teammate so he like he liked
regen health like crazy no because I'm
not reading health like crazy
oh please uh terrible
you like my warpin oh the ice I just
started playing this game and loved it
but then again I don't know what does
anyone people are looking for yeah that
that's like the other thing I think
there's still like at least like the
whole PC audience that never played
destiny one are probably still enjoying
it it feels really good on PC actually
um it's kind of hard to shift back and
forth between console and PC I'm totally
honest yeah
just don't have it anymore my aim is
poopy
and I am the weak link of this team
I can't every night I might yeah the
trade oh he actually rocketed him I
thought I got him with the grenade punch
nice work
like Golden Gun I don't know why Golden
Gun this round he should just did it
next round
it seems kind of silly like unnecessary
well we could've easily won the next
round but maybe you feel super confident
so remember only shoulder charge he's
the one shot I have smashed I'm assuming
the other team has smashed though I
haven't been playing super well enough
smash though
heavys about two shows above that they
do smash guy yeah I know but my my
destiny instincts I don't I don't use
the UI I'm gonna use these cheater UI
things you know there's a smash right
there everybody
I didn't killed him before he smashed
yeah running in circles Wow hey buddy
yeah smash does not feel like it last as
long anymore what the hell dude dude I
know we're fighting each other for kills
good one okay save me
oh he stud rockets what yeah I'm sure a
lot of people are gonna come back once
they do the do the big update for the
year well I don't know how much more
substantial we're gonna get in terms of
stuff coming out Johnny Rogers cuz you
know this is as good of a time as it's
gonna be to do do something regarding
destiny to you since there is an event
that will get people to come back to
play the game I think
so if not now then when we finally won I
finally won oh I got a crimson oh no as
a shader but May is the next DLC
supposedly yes I think so
get monster hunter a gift for you VLC
says just X Kaz
yeah it's true and it's true I gave them
a second chance with this and this is
what they released yeah well you know
hello doesn't matter if you win you get
the same [ __ ] country yeah they've never
really rewarded people for winning in
PvP other than like in trials and stuff
so you know I have no idea if there's an
I don't think there's a new raid goob I
think what it is is that there's another
raid lair when the expansion comes out
is my guess so it'll mean like one big
boss and like some platforming puzzle II
stuff which is a shame because in the
past there was definitely you know there
was something to look forward to with
the raids because there's so much bigger
in scale this time around not so much
fortunately so it is what it is energy
weapon that's good but yeah we probably
play like one more match call it a
stream but I do appreciate everyone
tuning in today sharing their thoughts
we are live every day at 11 a.m. if you
guys didn't know that already so you
know we'll have Monster Hunter on Friday
mark made a video stating goodbye
destiny and you're still here I actually
told them one his name's not Mark Johnny
his name's Mike my Hardy and I told them
like that's a great video because I
actually stopped playing destiny to
myself and started playing Monster
Hunter
now however regardless of if I was in
streaming this here today at GameSpot I
would have played this crimson event
anyways because as mentioned there are
some things that you can actually
tangibly get if you just play the game
and it's a good excuse for me to you
know do the knife all my friends
do the raid layer with my friends maybe
PvP a little bit probably not PvP so
much more so than maybe getting the five
matches out of the way and then I'm done
I'm good you know I got my destiny to
event you know through and I'm fine I'm
good you know so Johnny Rogers uh no
more lobby instead we kind of do these
in the office chat things oh god I got
melted um where we kind of just you know
talk about a cool game we're playing or
a game that you know a lot of people are
playing in the office and just kind of
sharing our thoughts on that instead so
look forward to that
instead we stream just like us playing
games chatting with you guys oh gosh
everyday whoa that guy is lagging or I'm
wagging
[Music]
he's got calling me
I don't think you'll be $150 in deep I
think what you should do is if there is
in fact a taking King type of destiny to
package coming out just wait till that
and that you'll get everything with that
taken King package we're like what is it
like um $50 $60 darkest the darkest
before I think is the trials scout which
is like really good apparently please
die I did not do enough damage sure I
moved a monster hunter uh I say yes
however there are some caveats with that
I mean it's not necessarily the easiest
game to just pick up and and get used to
so there is definitely a learning curve
we do get them okay
so just know that it's not necessarily
gonna be like super easy to get into I
guess or playing a clan or a group here
just trying different things Johnny I
feel like there's a lot of cool like
kind of like cooler talks in the office
cooler talks being like you know you go
to the water cooler and have
conversations or whatnot that you guys
don't get to see and we're trying to
bring some of those to the foreground
forefront so that you guys can check
those conversations out and enjoy them
sending that no yes or yeah as gube
mentioned drew playing what your friends
are also playing will probably help
because Monster Hunter it's a co-op game
just as destiny as a co-op game so do my
best to try to light show with this guy
oh please don't die with your own color
let's not have a point oh gosh do we
challenge the Golden Gun oh we got him
no he didn't
I'm gonna chill I am NOT pushing
you just chill why
now they got heavy too great oh wait
we're still up run gotta play tactically
gotta play tactically so is this the PvP
event where the winner doesn't matter I
mean it doesn't yeah it doesn't matter
later Vertigo hello crazy gamer bad
challenge bad okay my teammate was there
went by a smash
Oh Tiger knew me before he could smash
him we're fortunate I should have just
kept running and laying down grenades
thanks Johnny I think shreds
it's got explosive rounds if you're
curious the darkest before super stable
scout we need to get some kills here
though no we're gonna do it it's a good
try smashing and hoping for the best
although feeling like we're losing this
around so bad that's probably not worth
smashing
yeah you could do that Jam I mean like
your teammate might not be super happy
about it but you'll probably get your 5
matches and actually if we're close to
our 5 matches I might just finish the
five matches just to kind of like finish
it off
okay just call that round of a wash you
know that's what the dislikes
it's destiny - man it's a new it's the
new Cod it's the new game to hate oh I
really wanted to smash them they're so
bad it was a close if it was close I
would have smashed there for sure oh why
he's got Golden Gun again though it's
bad have fun playing Kingdom Come
deliverance 0h
I'm game fling
he's just waiting on the heavy crap have
you got fusion it's fine
can't kill us both
only one minute left
not good not good it's tied now probably
need to get to the heavy don't know if
I'll get to it soon enough
I think they're gonna get the head of
you
just lose on purpose in it no I mean I
don't know it's not it's not I roll so
I'm gonna play the last match just so I
can finish that thing up my a teammate
didn't do so hot but hey it's okay I
want to see this heart emote now I don't
think I have one to show it so you know
how it how it goes it is fair this could
be a good reminder of just you know the
lack of what people want in terms of
destiny you know it's fine
find other fun stuff to stream like
maybe fortnight or pub G or what we
already wants to hunter so don't really
need to double down on that yeah I don't
have a I'll get one from the yeah I'll
check that out and once I finish this
next match probably see how that goes
you know
but yeah do you appreciate you guys all
hanging out one more match to go to
finish the milestone and then I'll
probably be done with the event unless
my group decides to raid in which case
we'll probably do that so we could get
the ward Clif ornament so just so you
guys know if you guys do do the event
finishing the knife fall you're gonna
get the flaunting dance email which is
basically single ladies Beyonce song
dance if you do the raid you will get
the word cliff or raid or raid layer
you'll get the war cliff ornament from
the last chest and then if you do five
crimson day matches for the milestone
you're gonna get the crimson days fire
of the crimson days emblem and the tier
Strela ghost shell so and then by
participating in the crucible days or
crimson days crucible playlist you have
a chance to get the undeterred exotic
Sparrow those are the ten of like five
big things I guess bring back five date
Friday Night Fights like actual Friday
Night Fights
it used to be Wednesday night fights
actually which was like the worst
because we would drink in the middle of
the week and then I'd have to go to work
the next like day was like man I'll be
done with destiny too until the next
major update or the next DLC
well he's only an iron banner gear so
there's at least that sit there over
here
we should go to the heavy
Hevy yeah I take it all right wow this
is a pretty fun one huh
no actually no we're gonna die with full
power ammo or just kill them both
kind of blew my load there but I saw
both of them just kind of figured guys
spam it off before I die this is like
the pacifist run right now bad come on I
guess my fire was too far behind well I
would not do that and we're back to even
Wow I'm awful you just lose no you
killed one back off you can't hear me
but back off that guy using sweet
business not worth trying to Tiger smash
there my man what's up Josh that was
dumb I take I take full responsibility
for us losing there I did not need to go
in like that I could get through another
grenade just couldn't stand how slow the
game was going when really you should
play slow if you want to win because I
can't play fast to win whatever happened
a future man does he still like she's
still screaming wait oh it assumes all
right double maid
don't spend all that ammo in one place
colony pretty good turns out it's a G
Cal invite he does but he built the DJ
setup in his basement does music shames
ya interesting thought his other strands
were all I would assume to his DJ
streams are just as entertaining but are
you going in
all right the trade it's fine oh you
still there's no machines nice I don't
know why we're even engaging show
should be fine even if my partner dies
here we'll be fine
assuming I made a place to hide I'm just
gonna chill over here dance actually
that's not the right song well one
thought I could slide to the stairs I
was wrong oh that guy's actually using a
real gun now stop using sweet business
larious
now show them the true meaning
poly armory don't know what that means
dance for me what is that guy doing
partner
just shoot him he literally flew up
right above you
and saw that coming
know what my teammates not near where he
just smashed pretty bad team shot him
we good we good done to dance
besides monster hunter world what is a
good multiplayer game that came out yeah
you kind of have to want to be willing
to grind in Monster Hunter or you have
to get the thrill of wine to learn to
fight against new enemy types but I mean
there's still definitely some some
grinding that's going to be done to get
certain gear sets and whatnot but the
gear sets are also like a draw like a
motivating factor it's like you do you
do the farming or the grinding to get
the gear sets that you want you know
here you take the heavy not that you can
hear me but I've taken the heavy every
time so you go ahead have yourself a
little fun wait what okay fine
don't take the heavy and I will got him
can't escape all four spiders I don't
run to your partner and the game's over
nice to go I don't know what though
destiny two's grind is a lot more
rewarding than Monster Hunters oh it's
it depends on how you look at it I don't
totally agree with that statement but
it's not incorrect I guess well you know
what it is maybe it's like when they die
when your teammate dies and you're near
them you then get more life back I guess
maybe either way we win
we did it I don't think I got a crimson
Ingram though ever so there's that
Humvee one quick scope well now that
would be if I ever played Nick
Marguerite and some call D pretty good
and they're two point six three Katie
anyways
I appreciate everyone that did stop by
hung out shared their thoughts on
destiny too clearly it's not a game that
necessarily everyone's still in love
with or maybe were ever in love with but
on the love factor don't forget your
loved ones tomorrow you know your mother
your sister maybe your significant other
anyone that's important into your life
if you want to buy into the Valentine's
Day thing I would say get a card get
some chocolates maybe don't don't don't
do the roses or flowers those are just
overpriced for a day but as I mentioned
Christmas Day event going on this week
in destiny to kind of like their
Valentine's Day event so make sure you
do that have fun
maybe not destiny but in real life and
if not you know it's all good get your
hearts out as a goob would say I don't
know if I'm doing a good job of making a
heart right now but it's such a rave
thing to do I thank you guys all for
tuning in and come back tomorrow at 11
a.m. when we'll be streaming another hot
game which I haven't decided
could be dynasty Warriors 9 if you're
curious about that game open-world now
by the way
dynasty Warriors 9 and Sam will be back
Sam
light hammer will be back on Thursday so
come hang out with her on Thursday and
Friday of course we're gonna have
Monster Hunter World Fridays with Ben
and John Luke and I think we're gonna
have bonus stream on Friday because
bayonetta and Bayonetta 2 will be
available on switch so you might see
Charlie twice that day potentially
because I won't be here Friday
but yeah thanks for everyone thanks
everyone and I hope you have a good rest
of your Tuesday later
[Music]